hey we just finished watching all the
gifts you guys sent us for the gift
contest it took us like three hours to
watch all of them because we watched all
of them we laughed our butts off for
most of that time so we can't show you
every single gift this video will be way
too long and probably get kind of boring
at least half the gifts were of Sam
going in the knife video and we have
some great prizes going out to the
winner so we have some monopods from i
footage there's a link in the
description if you want to check them
out they some fidgets winners are going
out not just the winners but also the
either the ones who completely missed
the mark or didn't quite get the concept
one dude send us a dot WMV so he gets
the fidgets spinner prizes as well
including a one of the limited-edition
katakana corridor hats which are no
longer available in the store sit back
relax and let us entertain you with the
best of the best from the second annual
contest all right guys everybody gather
round to show the winner
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah that was pretty good yeah that one
should be up dude Joseph sands of time
this guy sent us a gift but the gift is
actually just one frame it's a one frame
one gift but then the folder of her hood
spinner and sure they're a total
stranger who I obsess over via the
internet I feel relieved it's time for
me to live
did you see this short film posted on
the subreddit no I've been told to
ignore the subarray because gifs are
gonna get someone posted this cool short
film on the subreddit I think Renan
would really like it other spiders no no
no spiders legit serious no spiders it
changes that was me oh I think I know
what this is this is like what Facebook
does but he first showed it to me my
pictures were showing uh yeah this is
posted by many cow on our subreddit it's
the exact same sort of thing that
Facebook does when they make like those
compilation videos where they throw all
your photos in there and stuff yeah it's
just a really funny idea in it super
smooth really creative so I can pet them
or door when there's no more pizza when
there's no more pizza
that's so relatable hate when I run out
of pizza I've been out of pizza for the
last two weeks looks like your TV let me
shrink this down here so we can get a
better sense of just how many freaking
sound clips are in this project right
now
I opened the addition file I didn't see
any of your work in there oh come on
come now come now young carp oh [ __ ]
you probably just hit the old you open
the old one probably oh wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait was I already
working from a backup hold on hold on
hold on companies really need to figure
out the best like autosave solution just
so that this sort of thing doesn't
happen
is that really it no yeah no we're good
it's just it says a lot of these files
are offline no see I put to see this
cheering in here yeah yeah this is what
I put in but it's offline when you were
working on the sound design for this
project
you saved the session file locally on
your computer so that means each time
you drag the clip in it would say well I
went to your computer and I was trying
to open it up so I was trying I was just
open anything up here
everything was unlinked I go over to
your machine and I find the file you're
working off of and it's on your C Drive
and that means everything all every
single sound effect you're putting in
you know how out of audition converts it
it was also on your C Drive so I had to
collect the entire session all the files
duplicate them put it all on the server
as a single piece oh thanks man wait
yeah this morning yeah oh that dudes
real chill did you not know about it No
so you just now discover that your phone
was missing yeah you got it back I I
work really hard to not have my phone in
my hand like I needed like organize
these files really pretty this is like
turning into a [ __ ] right now Oh
baby this whole morning yes Ryan
love what they have going on can't wait
to see more this is Ryan super saying
[Music]
every single oh yes let's listen we're
I'm glad and let you fix it Sam I've
been fixing it yet because I don't know
this is the best one why is everything
offline
I'm so confused why this happens I guess
it has something to do with the fact
that we've got a 2,000 sound clips in
this I saved it in the main folder last
night
yellow crazy son y'all are crazy link
all media crowd boo strong 4800 ou one
crowd boom strong there's one should
find them all now there we go
I think it's back alright guys here are
the top picks is the ones that had the
most effort or the most creativity
involved yep or just based up taste
alright this one which is all the gifts
pretty great next up we got this one the
Sam tripping balls the gradient in the
noise map for that like it looks super
cool next up I got this really long one
that's an entire scene with stories and
everything the price level is long day's
work dude so uh how's it feel living
video go viral did a great job you and
Mike did a great job
if I roll we're talking what does the
studio close it well it's on the front
page of Reddit right now so I was kind
of crapshoot when you upload a video you
don't quite know if it's gonna hook
people's imagination or not like when a
video actually does and like people
really like it it's a really good
feeling today and I think it's a
testament to like everybody who worked
on it doing a great job like the effects
are great they really didn't have that
much to do with that that was random
Peter just killing it and yeah it was
really nice really combination of Sam
and Mike cranking on it I'm thankful you
guys kind of came out with an outline I
did some writing for some dialogue stuff
we mounts back and forth and then what
are the tribute what's the troubie fo
420 420 thousand Mary
this video could get a million views in
a day yeah it might yeah yeah more time
ready boom oh yeah here's the cheese one
so funny all right those are the good
ones here is the winner on the quarter
Digital hip competition the invisible
bike visible fiery grave it is like the
actual like visual effect that comes out
of it those like it's so yeah and either
place to the side of the hands I think
this is first place this is second place
this is third place this is fourth place
this fifth place oh sorry
I left out a major winner an actual real
winner here is number one the one with
Ren Bing and the gift is talking about
how using all the gifts is number two
this is number three Sam tripping out is
number four we're gonna contact winners
thanks so much for participating in this
competition it was a lot of fun to watch
these gifts good stuff guys it's brought
back a lot of good memories anything
that's alright so that about wraps up
the contest here as you saw there's a
lot of great submissions a lot of really
funny ideas but we didn't get to
everything so if you made a cool gift
and you want to show it to everybody go
post it on the corridor subreddit our
slash corridor it's a great way to show
the things that you're making that are
related to the channel whether you're a
filmmaker interest in the hobby or just
like the stuff we make or want to just
talk about nerdy things like like we do
and we actually all spend time there at
the subreddit I go there every day and
read stuff go there share your gifts
laugh at the gifts you like up vote the
ones there good and you should go check
out the gift contest from last year
there's a clickable link on the screen a
lot of great laps were had alright guys
until next year see ya
actually no I'm I'll see you tomorrow
the next video too